on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City
tonight taking you to power the new
British Chancellor lays waste for the
prime minister's own controversial
economic plan so there's the country on
the brink you've got another leader
and the man who tried to kill a
president John Hinckley Jr's attempted
assassination of Ronald Reagan changed
the course of U.S history he's now a
free man but is he a changed man tonight
he joins me for his first ever
International TV interview
from New York this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from New York City and
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored I
might be three and a half thousand miles
away but don't worry I can still call
out the incumbent and Reckless clowns
currently running Britain into the
ground from right here in Manhattan this
trust is now a Lino a leader in name
only a puppet prime minister the Holden
to bank benchers who want to out into a
chancellor who agrees with her about
absolutely nothing today Jeremy Hunt did
this
firstly we will reverse almost all the
tax measures announced in the growth
plan three weeks ago it is not right to
borrow to fund this tax cut beyond that
the Prime Minister and I have agreed it
would not be responsible to continue
exposing public finances to unlimited
volatility in international gas prices
there will be more difficult decisions
I'm afraid on both tax and spending
unbelievable devastating in four simple
steps he reversed everything his boss
his current boss has done as prime
minister subjecting her to the fastest
and biggest humiliation of any prime
minister in modern history the only
thing he didn't reverse was lifting the
cap on Bankers bonuses because let's be
honest they are the people who really
need most help right now
trust promised more spending less debt
and lower taxes all funded by a magical
growing pie but now we're getting the
exact opposite her plan is in Ruins and
so is her credibility even President
Biden can see it speaking this weekend
he made an unprecedented and merciless
intervention
well it's predictable I mean it was I
wasn't the only one that thought it was
a mistake
anyway I just think I I disagree with
the policy but that's up to Great
Britain to make that judgment not me
well Great Britain's made his judgment
trust is not fit to be our leader this
evening she sat gomlessly like some kind
of brain dead zombie next to a child so
as he dismantled her entire economic
strategy and even as he spoke a new poll
gave labor a staggering 36-point lead
the biggest for any party by any
pollster since Blair swept into power in
1997. the Tories must now urgently
decide if the chaos of a fifth leader in
six years is worse than the ongoing
chaos of Liz truss and if they can't
they must call an election and let we
the people made that decision and choice
prime minister let me remind you what I
said to you on the day you took office
you list trust wanted this job you've
spent weeks promising us that you can
fix it you have the solutions well
Britain needs you to keep that promise
and keep it fast and will be very
unforgiving if you fail us
we have failed us mistrust you failed us
dismally and we will be unforgiving you
must now resign as a matter of urgency
well more on the British political
dumpster far in a moment also tonight
I'll be speaking exclusively to John
Hinckley Jr the man who tried to
assassinate President Reagan that
interview in full later in the program
but first I want to know why he's broken
his silence to talk to me tonight John
Hinckley Jr thank you very much indeed
for joining me
hello peers how are you I'm fine thank
you I just I'm curious I guess why are
you doing this interview and what do you
hope to achieve from it
well I'm doing some interviews because
I'm just trying to get across to the
public
that I'm not the person that I was all
those years ago there's been an image of
me for many years
a really negative image and I'm trying
to change that and show them that I'm a
totally changed person
than I was so long ago
obviously you took part in one of the
most infamous moments in modern American
history
when you look back on that day it was
actually my 16th birthday March the 30th
1981. I remember very well what happened
I was celebrating with my friends and
then we heard about this assassination
attempt on the president which
fortunately was unsuccessful but when
you look back on that what are your
feelings about what you did that day
I just feel so terrible about what I did
um I was right in the middle of a really
severe mental illness
I had a really bad depression and I had
some delusions going on
and um let me looking back on it now I
just it's like a whole nother lifetime I
just can't imagine doing what I did
I'm sure you're aware that there are
many people who feel you shouldn't be
free that if you try and kill the
president then you deserve to spend the
rest of your life in prison uh do you
understand that and you understand why
people feel that way
I understand that because it's such a
serious heinous crime but you know it
was 41 years ago and um a lot has
happened to me in those 41 years
and I'm hoping to uh show the public
that you know I'm a I'm a good person
now and I'm trying to do some good
things with my music and my art
well John Legend Junior I will come back
to you later for more from this
interview I appreciate you joining us
tonight thank you very much uh Hey with
me in New York a former conservative MP
Louise mench editor at large at the U.S
financial times uh Jillian tet another
author and journalist Vicki water
welcome to my my stunning pack tonight
this is really on every level
we wanted you because you are the most
talked about journalist in Britain uh
this week because in one beautiful
little clip on live television in
Britain you managed to perfectly
encapsulate exactly the fast of what has
been happening with our economy this was
in response when you were asked you know
it's Jacob Reese Mark had tried to claim
that all this stuff going on had nothing
to do with Liz truss's budget and he
replied as follows
well to use non-technical term that's
pretty much bollocks
um I think that for the most part it
really was the budget and the way it was
delivered and the message inside it
which sparked the beginning of the
crisis
well look other shows would censor these
comments we are called Piers Morgan
uncensored for a reason and honestly
nobody has said it better because it has
been an absolute load of all bollocks
hasn't it Jillian well Bullocks as
Charles were actually transcribed as
Bullocks and so they've all been mooing
and you know or not booing but you know
we're all trying to get our heads around
all this chaos obviously uh back home
it's it's pretty unprecedented it's
pretty extraordinary it's pretty
depressing actually
um just want to play a little mashup of
what was going on even this afternoon
for those who've missed this watch this
with apologies with apologists to the
leader of the opposition and the house
the piano is detained on urgent business
but where is the prime minister hiding
away dodging questions scared of our own
shadow the light is not for turning up
well the prime minister is not under a
desk with regrets she is not here for a
very good reason I guess under this Tory
government everybody gets to be prime
minister for 15 minutes
foreign
the prime minister is not under a desk
was one of the things that had to be
defended as an official statement quite
extraordinary scene there but Julian
there's a serious point to this that
even by reversing everything today that
might calm things in the short term but
there's already been significant damage
caused by this mini budget which is
irreversible absolutely I mean the thing
about Britain was that the way it ran
its finance and economy used to be
considered really really boring and
boring was good because it was
technocratic and predictable and now as
I said last week on Channel 4 as well
basically you know Britain's starting to
look like Italy in the sense you've got
big political instability you've got
policy making uncertainty you've got
Financial Market stresses all of which
have been considered to be Italian in
the past Britain hasn't got the good
food unfortunately but um you know this
is a kind of problem that is going to be
very hard to fix because as we all know
in relationships trust when shattered is
very hard to foreign
in the world of Finance have you ever
seen a more cack-handed budget in your
life in terms of consequence and then
the unraveling the short answer is we're
seeing this kind of pattern a lot of
times before but in Emerging Markets
right developing markets where
essentially you have interest rates that
are very high in the markets because
investors demand some kind of
compensation for political risk if
you're really boring you don't need that
kind of risk premium and that's
unfortunately what we've seen creeping
into the UK definitely Louise mentioned
you often defend the indefensible when
it comes to your party
um you're going to try and defend trusts
or no I'm not I think I think it has to
be for her uh Jeremy Hunt has just
restored some confidence to the markets
by basically junking everything yes that
Liz trusts herself put forward and ran
on as leader in a leadership contest
that went on for far far too long over
the summer and there's only one way out
of this for the conservative party and
that is to pull off the plaster as
quickly as possible take the medicine
get rid of Liz truss and do it quickly I
mean in a way they've done that by
unraveling the entire budget the only
thing they haven't done is get rid of
trust the argument is well you know the
rules say there has to be a leadership
contest within another year or so on but
they're going to change the rules and
just do this now the rules can be
changed the thing that matters now is
not internal Tory party rules it's the
British constitution and a prime
minister is somebody who can command a
majority of the House of Commons Liz
truss is already well on her way to not
being able to do that she has to do the
Patriotic thing I know it's embarrassing
and I know it's difficult the Patriotic
thing is for Liz trust to resign and for
the conservatives to coalesce around one
leader and start to put this right why
should it why should we give the Tories
any more time why should we not now
actually go straight to a general
election and let the British people
decide which judging by tonight's poll
which is catastrophic for the Tories I
mean this is Wipeout territory the like
of which we've not seen since Blair in
97. but what real moral right do the
Tories have after this Fiasco which will
cause so much harm to millions of people
with mortgages that might nothing else
what moral right do they have to try and
stumble on rather than go to the
electorate I don't think they will
stumble on as long as they get rid of
trust and put in a strong consensus
leader but you're right and I'll be
honest with you turkeys don't vote for
Christmas if there was an election
tomorrow the conservative party would be
wiped out and you have to remember
despite the current chaos and the
disaster of Liz trust conservatives are
conservatives for a reason I don't think
putting uh running a general election
having every single socialist guy who
supported Jeremy corbyn and didn't
expect to win all of a sudden catapulted
into Parliament talk about unintended
consequences that wouldn't be good
either so you can say Do they have any
rights I think they've actually got a
duty to get rid of her get their act
together the get a consensus leader and
change the keyboard there was a moment
when she addressed the media very
briefly uh the other day and there was a
bunch of I think will become her Legacy
look at this
uh
um
uh
Robert peston
I mean completely and utterly clueless
like the proverbial rabbit trapped in
headlights for you living here in
America we've been back in Britain we've
had a good laugh about Trump and Dopey
Biden falling asleep and I was going I
think the laughter stopped now the
laughs on us isn't it when it comes to
world leadership well you know I think
I'm the only American I don't sound it
but I am the only American you're an
American I am yes
it's very advantageous the
um you know I think I've probably looked
at this with the greatest distance of
probably all of us and I have to say I'm
just totally
bewildered
um on every you know I mean Liz truss
had time the queen died she had time and
you know Jillian test one of my closest
friends I've been looking to ask her for
several weeks could they not just add up
I mean if you're going to well that was
the point they didn't even try it they
didn't even try to do the same as it
seemed to me and they hadn't even shared
their thoughts with the cabinet it's
quite extraordinary well and and I would
you know so my my thoughts as the
American at the table I did I think the
one thing that helped Liz trust by the
way was Joe Biden
um talking down to her right you know
British people don't like it when
American presence talk down yeah to them
to be honest he's in no position to
lecture anybody about the economies I've
written in a column for this yes I loved
your column I completely agree I write
about uh private equity and hedge fund
uh owners all the time and Joe Biden
campaigned on getting rid of carried
interests which is a very unfair tax
loophole and his latest act absolutely
kept that in so he's not one to talk
let's let's sort of move to just running
a little low on time I want to move to
another uh issue I have today which is
these oils stop the oil protesters back
in the UK who started doing more and
more acts of wanton vandalism we've got
a little mashup of their Antics in the
last few days
all right
[Music]
this way
we've seen them dropping milk in
supermarkets at a time of a cost of
living crisis like which most of us have
never seen which seems an extraordinary
act for trying to get public sympathy
they've also been lying in the middle of
roads and closing big Bridges and big
tunnels and so on so I think my
overriding view of these people is the
more of this they do whatever the merits
of the calls that they're fighting for
which is climate change and about the
over excessive use of oil around the
world it's eroding by the second with
these acts of childish Petty pathetic
vandalism Am I Wrong does anyone want to
defend these people well I'd personally
say that I agree that that kind of Act
is not helpful for the cause at all it
makes it look like it's all a kind of
teenage protest and a kind of sulky
teenager pouting if you like
um but at the same time I think that it
also reflects deep concern about what
the UK is going to do next on this front
the UK did have a pretty sensible set of
policies one of the many things that
appeared to be happening under trust was
that some of these were being reversed
and so at the same time as saying that
this kind of act probably milked down in
the supermarket is pretty dumb it's
equally dumb to not have some kind of
coherent government policy to switch
rapidly to renewable energy I mean these
things can both be true I mean my view
about the renewable energy of the fossil
fuels is you can't do it all in one go
and my God we've discovered this year
that the energy situation is pretty
desperate for everyone and in the short
term we need fossil fuels just to
survive but we are going to have to try
as a planet to move to Renewables the
issue at the moment is cost and
availability right yes absolutely but I
don't think that these guys should be
part of that debate that's a serious
debate for serious people and when I
look at that picture of them throwing
paint at Van Gogh sunflowers I felt
anger internally and that's what they
wanted me to feel if you think about
their protests attacking The cenotaph
Dumping a bucket of feces over a statue
of Captain Tom they are not actually as
childish as you think they are carefully
designed to provoke an emotional
reaction of Fury in the British people
it's a bit like when the vegans start in
the extreme vegan start shrieking away
and doing Mad things it makes me want to
go and order a Big Mac
um Vicki before we'll let you go I want
to talk this quickly about another story
news this week prince Andrew and Gillian
Maxwell her first interview from the
prison you obviously had an interest
here you had a big scoop about Etsy
which got suppressed
um
Guillain Maxwell comes out supportive of
Andrew his friends are telling the
papers this is the last thing he needs
right now as he tries to rehabilitate
himself what do you make of it
you know I think Gillen Knightsville is
very clever and it was very clever
messaging on her part
basically what she was telegraphing in
just a few sentences was you know prince
Andrew is still in my world uh Bill
Clinton she called him a special friend
you don't want to be called my dear
friend by convicted well no it's not
good it's not good for them but I think
it's telling about her State yeah of
mind which speaks again to the trial
that we went through and is there any
dance for you that Guillain Maxwell was
up to her neck in it as much as Epstein
that she knew a lot of the stuff that
was going on
no I sat through the trial she she
clearly knew what was going on she was
not
by any stretch the only person who knew
what was going on and and what's really
troubling and why I think she's called
out these men is that the men are who's
missing from this story okay that
because she wrote a done a great podcast
on that and it really is very unfair how
the spotlight has been so much on the
woman and so well because the man killed
himself right
well I agree with lots of very powerful
people and they should all be held to
account I totally agree before we go
final one word answer will this trust
survive till the end of the week
probably till the end of the week but
not much longer than that
um I hope not I'm going to Echo my very
clever friend I'm going to say an
emphatic simple because I did say one
word answer no she'll be gone at the end
of the week and if not the world's gone
nuts thank you to my stellar pack this
is we'll have to do this again I love
this thank you very much we're coming
next an exclusive interview with a man
who tried to assassinate President
Ronald Reagan John Hilton Jr will join
me
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook and I'm
censored from New York City tonight
exclusive interview with a man who
almost changed the world and who some
people believe should still be locked up
in prison for the rest of his life
it was 30 seconds and Six Bullets that
changed American history
March the 30th 1981 a man opened fire on
President Reagan and he left the Hilton
Hotel in Washington DC a bullet
ricocheted off the president's limo and
lodged within an inch of his heart
almost killing him
Reagan's press secretary James Brady was
paralyzed for life the gunman was John
Hinckley Jr the mentally ill 25 year old
was obsessed with a young actress Jodie
Foster depressed and delusional he
thought killing the president could win
her affections
after 12 days in hospital Reagan made a
full recovery serving two terms as one
of America's most popular ever
presidents Hinckley was found not guilty
of attempting Murder By reason of
insanity but spent 30 years in
psychiatric care and another 10 under
close supervision this year he was
granted full freedom
the whole world knows his name and what
he did tonight they'll hear his story
and it's uncensored
well John Hinckley Jr rejoins me now
John Hinckley thank you again for coming
on the program I appreciate it and you
said that you want to change I guess
people's perceptions if they have a
negative view of you just to take you
back to that day when Ronald Reagan was
was shot by you along with three other
people what Memories do you have of your
actions that day
foreign
I just remember
I was at a hotel in Washington DC
and I I happened to have the uh the
newspaper
before me I saw the president's schedule
for that day
and uh that's where how I knew where he
would be that day
and I think I went I think I went and
got some breakfast
and then I went up to the hotel
and in those days it was easy to get
pretty close to a president of course
that's all changed now but
back then it was pretty easy to get
close to the president and unfortunately
I was able to go through with the crime
do you remember actually firing your gun
not not anymore no I don't
your motivation at the time albeit you
it was decided that you were suffering
from severe mental illness so not
responsible directly for your actions
was that you'd become obsessed with the
movie star Jody Foster after watching
the movie Taxi Driver in which a
character does actually plot to
assassinate a presidential candidate
do you recall any of your feelings about
Jody Foster that would lead you you know
I think you were trying to impress her
by doing this but do you recall that the
build up of feelings that you had about
her that would lead you to do such an
extreme Act
well I mean I had first seen her I
believe in the movie Taxi Driver and
that was in 1976 I believe
and this Obsession that I developed this
kind of built over the next several
years
to where in 1980
she went off to college at Yale
University
and I went to Yale to uh follow her
and try and find her
and uh that just didn't turn out that
turned out badly
and so uh I just kind of my thinking
just
went very uh negative and that's why
when ahead with the shooting
what do you feel about Jody Foster today
well I have very kind feelings for her
you know I'm so I've I've apologized to
her for bringing into all of this
and I just wish her a very good life
there will be a lot of people uh John
Hinckley who
would have just heard the last few
minutes of what you've been saying and
felt a chill got their spine that
somebody could stalk a major celebrity
for several years I think at one stage
you also stalked Jimmy Carter before you
fired these fateful shots at President
Reagan which was faithful for at least
one of the people you shot James Brady
who ended up dying many years later from
his injuries but they'll feel a chill
that must find thinking somebody that
can do all this have such a dangerous
Obsession that led to such dangerous
stalking and then the ultimate Act of
danger of trying to assassinate a an
American president that that person
should never be released and there's
been a lot of anger since you were given
full Freedom
um what do you feel about that I mean do
you feel yourself that you it is right
that you should be released I mean I'll
give you an analogy Mark Chapman shot
John Lennon I think a year before you he
remains incarcerated with no real sign
of of being released at all but that's
because he killed Lenin but at least one
of the people you shot died as a result
of those injuries years later do you see
a distinction between the two of you
between you and Mark Chapman you think
it's right you're free
as
I see a big distinction because
uh Mark Chapman was found guilty and he
he's been in prison all these years I
was never in prison peers I was in a
hospital
for 35 years receiving treatment
I was found not guilty by a reason of
insanity and sent to Saint Elizabeth's
and I received treatment all these years
in
my my family stood behind me and I had a
great lawyer Barry Levine
and you know I I feel like my my release
was very Justified
but do you understand why many people
feel angry because if you've been
successful in your mission to which was
premeditated you've already said that if
you succeeded in killing Reagan you
would have changed the course of
American history of global history
turned out to be a very popular
successful president but you would have
snuffed him out of the very start of his
presidency do you understand why some
people feel enraged that you've been let
out and allowed to lead a completely
free life
I underst I can understand that yes I
just hope that they would also
understand that I'm a completely changed
man now
uh I just it's it's been so long ago
that that happened and a lot of good
things have happened to me since then
to where uh I just hope people who have
negative feelings about me can
take another look at me and listen to my
music I tell people if they want to get
to know me to listen to my songs
because uh all of my songs are uplifting
about overcoming hard times
and then get to know me pretty well by
listening to my music I mean you've
actually you've been trying to perform
live at music venues but they've all
been canceled because of outcries and
threats to people's lives and security
issues and so on it may be impossible
for you to pursue this kind of career
publicly by performing which again it
suggests there's a lot of anger out
there and concern that people may take
the law into their own hands because
they feel that Justice wasn't properly
served
well I keep trying I mean you're right
I've had about five or six venues cancel
on me because after the concert gets
announced
they start receiving negative backlash
and they back out of the concert that's
happened about six times
so I'm I'm gonna keep trying but um
hoping for a venue that'll Stand By Me
just to be clear about one thing you you
did want to kill President Reagan right
well I suppose they'll suppose so back
then I did
[Music]
um
I'm just so glad I didn't I did not
succeed
and obviously James Brady as I say died
many years later from the injuries from
you shooting him it was paralyzed for
life it ruined his life what are your
feelings towards the Brady family who I
mean at the very least I would imagine
are pretty concerned about the fact
you've been let out
well I just wish them all the good
health in life and I I wish they could
just forgive me that I wouldn't blame if
wouldn't blame them if they don't
forgive me but I wish they could
because I'm sure sorry for what I did
have you ever heard from any of the
Reagan family directly
no I'm not and I'll see all these years
I've had a court ordered to where I
could not communicate with the victims
of the shooting or the or their families
but even now that I don't have that
court order anymore I don't I don't
think they want to hear from me to be
honest
so I'm just going to try and you know
let them have their
distance okay I'm gonna take a short
break John Hinckley Jr we'll come back
with more my exclusive interview with
the man who tried to kill a president
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan uh
uncensored from New York City more from
my exclusive interview with the man that
tried to kill President Reagan John
Hinckley Jr rejoins me now John Hinckley
uh do you still take medication for the
severe mental illness that you had
I do appears I take two psychiatric
medicines
and what impact do you believe the
medicine has had on you
uh one's an antidepressant and you know
it just prevents me from getting
depression and
um I think they are effective and I have
no problem taking the medicines
when was the the moment for you that you
became aware of the enormity of what
you'd done
I think after I got hospitalized maybe
about
six months later
[Music]
um
it all kind of just dawned on me that
what I did was so terrible
and I think that was the start of my
recovery
I mean if you'd actually killed Reagan
obviously you would never have been
released from prison
have you thought about that
that's probably true
it changed security around presidents
irrevocably you know I've been around a
few uh of the more recent presidents and
the security around them is
extraordinary as a result of what
happened that day what do you feel about
about guns you obviously used a gun to
cause Carnage that day nearly to kill
the president it's an ongoing debate an
issue in America do you feel there
should be as there are now many more
restrictions around the president do you
feel there should be more restrictions
around guns themselves for The Wider
populace
I do
I do I think I think there are too many
guns in America to be honest
uh it's just kind of a very volatile
time right now
and it's it's not good that there's so
many guns in America
when you did what you did uh John
Hinckley what was your family reaction
to it did they stand by you did they
disown you
my family stood by me from the first
moment up till there till their my
parents deaths they stood by me all the
way
your father and my brother and sister
still Stand By Me your father I think
blamed himself for what had happened why
would he do that
I don't know but I certainly didn't
blame him I think he said that on the
stand during my trial
but I never had that feeling of blaming
him
when you look back at your life what do
you think prompted
such a severe mental illness that you
would commit the crime you committed
I I you know I had a good upbringing
with my family so I think if it was more
of a chemical imbalance
and my brain that caused the depression
which which led me to get
um estranged from my family that was
another thing that happened that was too
bad was
I got you know
um isolated from my family and that was
that was a took it took a bad turn after
that
many Americans I think believe in second
chances for people in in Rehabilitation
uh some don't but many do
but when you I mean do you tell people
who you are because your name is very
distinctive and if they if they work out
who you are how do they react
well here in Williamsburg you know
people are very nice to me and that's
the main reason I live here is
I get along fine here
uh my name is very well known
but I've always said that you know my
Persona is not that well known so I I
can go to the grocery store
or to other places and I don't get
bothered it's just it's just that my
name is so well known
there will be some people who don't
think we should even do this interview
who don't think you should be given the
oxygen of publicity what do you say to
them
well I'm glad you did because I'm trying
to get out the message that I'm a
changed person and if if all these years
people have had a negative image of me I
hope they can see me now as somebody who
has changed a lot
I suppose you'll be I thank you Peter
should give me that opportunity right I
mean the obvious question I guess I
would throw back at you for that is how
can we be sure you've changed you know
as you say you're still on medication to
control your illness what you did wasn't
just a one-off spontaneous moment of
violence it was after several years of
very Sinister stalking of a movie star
stalking of another man who became
president and then ultimately
shooting Ronald Reagan you know there
will be people watching this going well
he may say he's changed how can we be
sure
well I would say that I have a really
good track record you know I wasn't just
released one day from the hospital I got
released over a number of years my judge
you know gave me freedom and incremental
steps to see how I would do and I've
always done well with the freedoms that
he gave me
and I've proven myself to be you know a
very peaceful person now
and that's how I plan to live my life
do you want forgiveness is that is that
something you seek and if so who from
sure I think everybody wants forgiveness
if they if they need it and just from
the public at Large
and from the Reagan family and from
Jodie Foster from the family of James
certainly and the others the victims yes
the victim's family I wish I wish so
much they could forgive me
but as I said earlier I wouldn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't uh blame them if
they didn't forgive me but I wish they
would
in the case of James Brady of course as
I say he died from the uh wounds that he
suffered
um and it was designated homicide by the
coroner because of the year in a day
rule which existed at the time you could
not be tried for murder but do you
accept now that because you fired the
gun at James Brady that caused his
catastrophic injuries and subsequent
death that you were guilty of his murder
well I wouldn't say that I mean I
certainly caused him to have devastating
injuries but
um I believe he lived on for another 30
something years
um so I can't really see I'm the cause
of the murder
I mean it was ruled to homicide by the
coroner and he he suffered horrendously
from those injuries he was paralyzed for
the rest of his life
you did kill him didn't you I mean
there's no doubt about it ultimately you
killed him I understand
but you accept you killed him
I would say yes
John Hinckley uh
in the end people will watch this
interview and they may have already made
their minds up about you we're gonna
have a debate with three people with
different views about this in a moment
but what is your what's your final
message really to viewers who might
remain unconvinced by what they're
hearing and seeing and think actually
you know what he should he should have
stayed in prison if John Lennon's killer
is in prison why is this guy allowed to
to be out
well I would say to anybody who's
listening that
I'm a changed person and I was not just
sitting in prison all these years not
getting treatment I got I've gotten
treatment all these years
and I'm I'm just I don't have the same
thinking that I had back then and I've
shown through the through the freedoms
I've gotten over the past 10 or 15 years
that I do have a good track record of
being a very good law-abiding citizen
John Hinckley Jr I appreciate you
joining me tonight thank you very much
thank you
well coming next should John Hickory Jr
be locked up for life or do you deserve
to be allowed to walk free will be
debating that uh after the break
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm Beth Morgan in New York City and
I'll be here all week with all the big
names in the Big Apple
world heavyweight boxing champion Mike
Tyson
and the most controversial and most
watched man on American cable news
Tucker Carlson
join me and my guest totally uncensored
in New York City
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh uncensored in
New York some people believe John
Hinckley Jr should remain Behind Bars
the rest of his life or at least under
supervision so can someone who shot a
U.S president and as he by his own
admission killed somebody else in the
same shooting eventually after a number
of years ever be considered no threat to
society and regardless should he be
allowed to walk free well joining me now
is the former Navy SEAL who killed Osama
Bin Laden Robin Neal former White House
Press Secretary Ari Fleischer and Fox
News contributor Joe Concha well welcome
a great panel if I may say so
um Joe Khan let me start with you
because I found that a fascinating
interview not least the Revelation that
I got out of him at the end which was
this
ultimately you killed him I understand
but you accept you killed him
I would say yes
so that was John Hinckley Journey For
the First Time admitting that he did
Kill James Brady albeit it took 30 odd
years for James Brady to die from the
wounds he suffered that day what did you
make of that confession and does that
does that alter the balance really about
how he's been treated appears there
wasn't a lot of vigor behind that was it
you had to ask three times he said I
understand I understand he didn't say
outright I take responsibility I
apologize to the Brady family I
apologize to the Reagan family he seemed
to make that interview more about
himself than talking about the victims
and truly understanding what he did
particularly as it pertains to Brady
because he was in a wheelchair for 35
years what kind of hell is that right
and then as you said when he died it was
because of those gunshot wounds and that
becomes a homicide and I didn't realize
the coroner decided correct I just
didn't see a lot of remorse behind John
hinckley's rhetoric do you think he
should have been free no absolutely not
I can't see any advanced country it's so
hard to imagine trying to assassinate a
sitting Pres president and then you send
out a tweet when you get out after 41
years two months 15 days Freedom At Last
as if he was the victim somehow right
Robert Neal what do you think of this
it's complicated I think it's not an
easy situation he obviously did suffer
from a severe mental illness which all
the experts said through treatment he
had come through and was no longer a
danger to society I believe in
Rehabilitation it's the Bedrock of any
democracy in a sense and fair justice
but is it right that someone like him is
that well I believe in Rehabilitation
too but just the fact that he used
Devastator bullets which are designed to
explode a second time inside your victim
and he shot all six out of a revolver uh
that seems mentally sound enough to try
to murder someone especially a president
and hitting a police officer hitting the
press secretary and a Secret Service uh
agent I mean it's attempted murder in
the 33 years later through his honorable
now through his own admission right it
is it is homicide I mean that's
interesting because he was found not
guilty of attempting murder on the
grounds of insanity and then he was put
into you know a mental illness uh place
for the next 30 odd years and yet by
that admission he's conceding that his
actions that day actually constituted
murder right I don't know if it's double
jeopardy or or whatever it is I'm not an
attorney but just him admitting to it
right there and you know I mean he saw a
taxi driver he was influenced by a movie
that was influenced by an assassination
attempt who knows who knows what's going
through his head and he's trying to do
it he was actually going to go to try to
kill himself in front of Jody Foster
just to prove he loved her so there's
something there but if he's of sound
mind to get to find out where the
president is to get a weapon to get the
bullets to get close enough and then
take six shots he seems like he knows
what he's doing on balance would you let
him out and well it all depends uh it
depends on what the psychiatrists say
and I mean he seems like he's remorseful
but he also seems like he's kind of slow
because of all the medication he's
probably been on for three decades four
decades I mean that was slightly I have
to say Ari a concern to me was the way
he was speaking very slow pretty
ponderous uh and he admits he's on
several minutes occasions to this day to
control his depression and presumably
other feelings so he's not cured in any
sense from all his mental illness
problems and clearly at the time was
highly dangerous I mean it wasn't a
one-off he'd been stalking Jody Foster
for several years he stalked Jimmy
Carter uh he obviously planned the
attack on Reagan it's a very dangerous
individual that can do those things yeah
first and foremost let me just say
Pierce that interview was very
uncomfortable just watching it yeah you
know when you know a name it's an
Infamous name a person who tried to kill
a president
a gunman a shooter and then you see them
humanized you see another side of them
that you don't want to see you know
there's some comfort in just living with
the name of his Infamous killer and just
saying he got what he deserved and then
you see him you listen and it's
uncomfortable it's jarring I will say
this about mental illness people do
recover from mental disease and
particularly in the last many decades
treatments have gotten better the
medicines have gotten more efficacious
and Psychiatry Etc has gotten even more
refined to the point where people can be
mentally ill and are fine and are
outstanding members of our society the
difference is are you criminally
mentally ill or were you mentally ill
and now you're fine even if you are what
about if you have Joe the as he did the
awareness now to understand that his
actions killed James Brady by doing that
he's admitting to murder that is a very
serious crime that may be the year and
day you know element which prevented him
from being charged or convicted of that
but now he's got a mission yeah on the
record I'd be interesting to see what
that does legally I wonder but I think
at this point I don't think there is any
legal option now at this point right
because it's after the fact he's out who
who's going to go ahead and prosecute a
case that sort of thing here's my worry
and and when Rob was talking about it
talking about how slow he was in terms
of his answers what happens if he goes
off his medication then does he revert
back to the person he was before well
that's a word about criminal mental
illness versus mental illness and this
is where we don't know this is where you
just have to have Hope and Faith that
the psychiatrists and the experts who
were with him in prison and watched him
over the last 40 years know what they
were doing and it's interesting to me
Rob the Mark Chapman thing and I was in
a Maximum Security Prison interviewing
people this summer and he'd been in one
of them until recently and one of the
Gods said to me now he keeps being
refused parole probably because of his
notoriety because it was John Lennon he
killed right clearly this was on that
level of trying to kill President Reagan
but he did it turns out kill somebody
else a little bit over a long period of
time but he's now admitted
responsibility for that killing in terms
of infamy and notoriety I don't see a
lot of difference between Mark Chapman
and John Hinckley Jr now the glaring
difference is the secret service agent
McCarthy who faced the the fight like
you're supposed to in a protective
detail uh that's probably the reason
that he didn't kill the president and
because of something like that because
Ronald Reagan was able to elevate his
Legend past that no one really no he did
Hinckley got released unless we were
doing all this press right now unless he
came out and said and he's trying to
play concerts to sold out crowds that uh
venues that eventually cancel on him
anyway but um um yeah I mean the
notoriety is there an assassin president
itself it's going to be interesting to
see what happens after he just admitted
to what he did I mean if Lee Harvey
Oswald had survived and not been shot by
Jack Ruby and he'd been let out I think
all hell would have broken loose so you
know it's only the fact Reagan didn't
die that probably means John Hinckley Jr
is out and yet his actions did lead to
somebody else's death well I've heard
people say that this penalty for
attempted murder should be equal to
murder because you shouldn't get
rewarded because you had bad Angels you
know so there is something to be said
about that on the other hand that would
violate hundreds of years all right I'm
going to let you go without mentioning
your book
the title deception suppression snobbery
and bias sum it up in one sentence why
the mainstream media gets so much wrong
it just doesn't care
apart from me every company accepts it
every time he's got a book too you gotta
ask him put your name in the book come
on man the truth about Joe Biden is
horrible
and your books are all brilliant
great to people thank you very much
indeed that's it for me we'll be back
here from New York City tomorrow night
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
good night
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you